thousands still wait in freezing
conditions on the border belarus was
supposed to be their gateway to the eu
but as many who preceded them know this
frontier offers no immediate sanctuary
at a refugee center in poland we meet
people who were pushed between the
border guards of different nations their
ears fled syria passing through belarus
into poland only to be forced back
transported to lithuania and then sent
back again where a bella russian guard
cut the wire fence to poland he said he
was beaten by guards everywhere he went
when we arrived about
seven kilometers in the poland
i can't walk i can't please i can't
my bag
my friend is
he have a small broke in
her foot he can't walk
her eyes is
he can't see henin pregnant with her
fourth child escaped the violence of
iraq with her family crossing from
belarus into the no man's land of forest
bordering poland
during days and nights in the open she
worried her small children would not
survive
our situation was really really
difficult
all we had was a little bit of water
left in this bottle and i had to share
it amongst my children
me and my husband wouldn't drink
so nothing would happen to them
so they wouldn't die
as we spoke far-right sympathizers took
part in a polish independence day event
in warsaw calling for strong borders but
in this nation where the issue of
immigration divides there is also
compassion
sofia who wants to hide her identity
shows us the woods near her home where
migrants and asylum seekers have been
living rough
two weeks ago she was so moved by the
desperation of a group from kurdistan
she took them into her home
then they showed up from behind the
trees freezing a barefoot
and then i saw this girl she looked
really miserable
i just took off my own shoes and gave
them to her
one of many acts of kindness in a nation
where the government has taken a hard
line at the border a border which so
many still hope to cross
michelle clifford sky news poland